was ist eigentlich identität verleihen
was ich eigentlich bin ich überhaupt
was wir bis jetzt weiß ich ja dass man
genetisch bedingt wie ein charakterzug
hh wunder dass leeres blatt papier auf
welt sondern man hat vielleicht hätte
man tendenziell mehr in der führung und
schüttet oder mehr oxytocin frei machen
oder er apathisch ist und der punkte zur
liebe aufgewachsen ist also wenn ihr
jetzt sind zwillings sie war ziemlich
mini mini schwester wäre aber eine ganz
andere art macht sich bringen das
beispiel wo sie aktuell ist sie wäre in
syrien aufgewachsen im nachkriegs
gewählt wo bürgerkrieg herrscht wo armut
herrscht wo völlig andere verhältnis
einfach sind glaube dass sie denn ein
anderer aber die persönlichkeit und
wesenszüge entwickelt die wie ich obwohl
mir genetisch bedingt mit den möglichen
hier mit dem sender phoenix sind und
darum ist die persönlichkeit von einer
mensch ist das was mir ich bin geburt
das worum es hier um ist schluss alles
wo man erlebt habt boxer tötet jede
einzelne interaktion mit meiner mensch
all das macht dennoch der mich zu der
region wo ich jetzt bin und ich dort
noch der weg laufen bin ich eben andere
user wie ich kennengelernt habe und dass
ich wenn wir neue informationen dem
computer